[Music]
hey everyone welcome to their
installments of Harry Potter theory in
this video I'm going to be discussing
what dark arts spell book magic most
evil describes as follows of the Horcrux
wickedest of magical inventions we shall
not speak nor give direction I am of
course talking about Horcruxes Potter
more describes Horcruxes as follows if
Horcrux is created when a wizard takes
an object and binds a piece of their
soul to it
the purpose is immortality with the
logic going that as long as a piece of
your soul survives within the object and
you can never truly die it's magic so
dark so heinous that it was kept a
secret for most of the Wizarding World
yet despite many trying there are only
two known wizards to have discovered how
to perform it an ancient Greek Dark
Wizard called her for the foul who
created one Horcrux and Voldemort who
mastered the spell and created seven but
what I've always wondered is why the
Death Eaters didn't follow involves
footsteps and great Horcruxes for
themselves
shore-leave ultimate would have
entrusted someone like Bellatrix with
the knowledge of how to create one
wouldn't he Dumbledore once described
Tom Riddle's school gang as a mixture of
the weak seeking protection the
ambitious seeking glory and the thuggish
seeking a leader who could show them
more refined cruelty it was these same
students that are considered to be the
forerunners to what would become the
Death Eaters that we see later on in the
books and films Death Eaters up your
blood radical supremacists they cast
unforgivable curses without remorse and
torture muggles half-bloods and blood
traitors alike Death Eaters murder
people willy-nilly so it's not
unreasonable to expect that they would
be willing to murder to achieve
immortality furthermore the Death Eaters
were hell-bent on maintaining pure
magical bloodlines in the Wizarding
community and one very effective way of
doing that would be to remain immortal
as a pure blood so is it just that the
Death Eaters were left in the dark by
Voldemort unaware of what it was that he
had achieved or was it that the creation
of a Horcrux was just too imposing after
all Horcrux creation was even too dark
to be properly mentioned in a book about
the dark arts the following quote from
Voldemort suggests that at least some of
the Death Eaters knew something about
what he had done and then I asked myself
but how could they have believed I would
not rise
again they who knew the steps I took
long ago to guard myself against mortal
death he says it right there who knew
the steps I took surely this suggests
that he dedicated them on the process
here's what I think I think that
Voldemort told his followers about
Horcruxes but I don't think that he ever
delved into the specifics and I think
the reason that he never delved into the
specifics wasn't to hide the process
from them but because he didn't believe
that they were strong enough to go
through with it
creating a Horcrux is one of the most
difficult extreme and unknown magical
processes known in the Whistling world
and if it was hard going for someone
like Voldemort one of the most innately
powerful wizards of all time then how
can we reasonably expect that the Death
Eaters would be successful why would she
encourage and risk losing his followers
to a process that he knew they wouldn't
be able to handle I think that if he
were to have trusted anyone with this
knowledge it would have been Snape as he
was arguably the most powerful Death
Eater JK Rowling described the process
of creating Horcruxes as dangerous and
highly inadvisable yeah but I would
imagine that other people you know other
people are going to have tried I think
that it would be naive not to think that
people have been trying for a long time
and thought they succeeded and hadn't or
else or else you know maimed themselves
or killed themselves in an attempt it's
such a dangerous thing to do
additionally Voldemort didn't want the
world to know how he was immortal if
Voldemort told everyone about Horcruxes
and it became common knowledge what they
were he would be exposing his Achilles
heel so why didn't the Death Eaters
create Horcruxes because it was too much
for them to handle even Rin Dewalt who
was in contention with Voldemort as the
most powerful Dark Wizard of all time
never created a Horcrux Grindelwald was
so so knowledgeable and versed in the
dark arts but I have no doubt in my mind
that he knew what they were so I think
the fact that he never created one says
something however I think that I might
reserve the rest of my thoughts on
kinder world and Horcruxes for NVIDIA
the creation of Horcruxes is nothing to
scoff at and Slughorn encapsulate s' the
risk well with the following quote few
would want to live in such a form and
death would be preferable to most and
that's it for this video if you enjoyed
it please like the video and subscribe
to the channel until next time you're a
wizard Harry
[Music]